I have some amazing video from uh
radical republican congresswoman Lauren
bobert's recent debate as some of you
may know there is a 2022 midterm
election just around the corner now
about seven weeks away and some of the
main debates are starting We are
following very closely will John
fetterman and Mehmet Oz debate will
Herschel Walker finally agree to debate
Raphael Warnock and we are following all
of these Lauren bobert participated in a
debate against her opponent Adam Frisch
and she seemed to glitch very very badly
I don't know how many of you remember
when Marco Rubio during a Republican
primary debate in 2016 repeated the same
answer multiple times almost like a
glitchy robot I don't know how many of
you remember uh Kelly Lefler with her
radical liberal Raphael Warnock repeated
it repeated line during her debates with
Raphael Warnock Lauren bobert answering
close to a dozen questions by talking
about Nancy Pelosi and her con game it
is bizarre the bobert bot glitching
badly check this out candidate bobert
you have three minutes for that
Nancy Pelosi is running a con game in
Washington DC by the way Nancy Pelosi is
not Lauren bobert's opponent in case in
case you thought maybe that's why she
kept talking about Pelosi Nancy's con
game works like this fire Nancy Pelosi
Nancy Pelosi's I'm Adam Frisch I'm not
Nancy Pelosi I'm Adam Frisch I'm not
Nancy Pelosi Mitzi Pelosi uh plays in it
with Pelosi's con games Pelosi pushes
this but she will put a 2 000 page bill
on our desks at midnight Nancy Pelosi's
con game playing Nancy's con game to do
it yeah DC to play Nancy Pelosi's con
game I it makes me terribly sad when
Nancy Pelosi uses them it meant more
inflation more borrowing from China and
Pelosi knows it Pelosi's con Games This
was
um a blank check and okay
um
I'm Adam Frisch I'm not Nancy Pelosi
there was no interest and Nancy clothes
running under Pelosi Democrats are told
Lucy will not it's not time to help
Nancy Pelosi it is time to fire Nancy
Pelosi this election say no to Liberal
extremists and their army of IRS agents
I'm Adam Frisch I'm not Nancy Pelosi I'm
Adam Frisch I'm not Nancy Pelosi okay
um they have quite literally nothing to
offer there is nothing to offer there
and if you live in Lauren bobert's
District in Colorado it's a very red
District I understand that in bobert
um uh oh no actually this may be a
district that was redrawn so in any case
the previously bobert's District was was
a very red District
fine you don't like Nancy Pelosi but
don't you as a republican in her
District uh bobert's District still want
to hear some vision of what bobert will
do even if it's things that I don't
agree with don't their own voters want
to hear hear the types of regulations
I'm going to try to get cut here's how I
would change the tax code here's uh here
are the types of projects I would
support in order to bring dollars into
this District like it seems weird that
even the voters in Colorado are so
concerned with Nancy Pelosi in this way
that this would be an effective campaign
strategy But the saddest thing about it
is this stuff can probably work okay in
these highly weaponized electorates when
you have such a highly weaponized
constituency as Lauren bobert does
where they don't even really understand
the types of things Lauren bobert could
be advocating for for them they have
become propagandized to the point where
her own voters believe the role of
someone like bobert whoever is their
member of Congress is to do things like
fight the Pelosi Khan job we have such a
lack of education and understanding of
what these elected officials can even do
for us that there was a time where the
way that these debates would go would be
it would be a focus on the district and
sure yeah I mean listen Congress has a
investigative role when it comes to
whether to bring articles of impeachment
and Congress has an oversight role of
Court they choose the speaker of the
house yes but there was a time when what
voters wanted to hear
was their candidates understanding of
their District not what's going on in
Nancy Pelosi San Francisco or in
Washington DC understand what's going on
in our district hey you know what in our
district we have a dozen bridges that
are rated low whatever high risk of uh
possible failure
here are the three ways in which I'm
going to take care of those bridges in
our district so that all of your
commutes to work are safer so that we
don't risk huge traffic
interruptions when these Brit and loss
of life we prevent loss of life when you
and your kids are driving over this is
just an example but there was a time
where that was the approach and the
candidates would debate about well I
would like to better our infrastructure
this way
versus the other candidate wants to
better our infrastructure that way I'm
talking 30 years ago at least okay but
that's the way it used to be it's now oh
Nancy Pelosi's con job and this is
something they just they've tried before
with this stuff it fortunately failed
for Kelly Lefler but remember when Kelly
Lefler pulled this or tried to pull it
against Raphael Warnock during that
special election in 2021
the Democrats one of fundamentally
change America
opponent radical liberal Raphael Warnock
my opponent radical liberal Rafael
Warnock radical liberal Raphael Warnock
radical liberal Rafael Warnock radical
liberal Rafael Warnock radical liberal
Rafael Warnock radical liberal Rafael
Warnock right is a socialist radical
liberal Raphael Warnock radical liberal
Raphael Warnock radical liberal Raphael
Warnock radical liberal Rafael Warnock
radical liberal Rafael Warnock anyway it
goes on from there now fortunately in
that special election in Georgia it
didn't work and there were some special
Dynamics including quite frankly that
Trump and people around him were saying
it was all rigged anyway in Georgia in
November and that probably dissuaded a
lot of Republicans from even going out
to vote on January 5th in that special
election because listen even their dear
orange leader told them it's all rigged
your vote essentially doesn't matter so
a lot of special things went on there
and so it didn't work for Leffler but
this is not a new thing and it has
succeeded for them to some degree
because their constituents accepted they
have come to embrace a complete lack of
policy discussion in exchange accepting
things like well warnock's a socialist
and Nancy Pelosi's running a con job
let's see how it works out for them in
November next week on 9 19 September 19
we will be doing our next one day
membership special folding in many new
members into the ranks of membership I
hope
if you've been thinking I would get a
membership but it's got to be a good
deal get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com and then next Monday 9
19 you'll get an email from us bright
and early in the morning telling you how
to take advantage of this great
membership discount
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below